foreign
boot camp can be a challenging task with
so many options available how do you
know which one is the right for you well
we are here to help in this video we
will discuss the top 5 online boot camps
in 2023 as voted by the students who
have taken this courses we have sourced
the internet for testimonials from
individuals who have completed this boot
camps and you can find their experience
on our YouTube channel from Hands-On
projects to expert instructions this
bootcamp offers a comprehensive learning
experience that can help you achieve
your career goals in Ai and ml coding
data science data analytics and cyber
security so let's dive in and explore
the top 5 online boot camps of 2023 as
rated by the people who have taken them
accounts have become increasingly
popular for people to learn new skills
improve their career prospects and adapt
to the changing job market some benefits
of online boot camps include flexibility
affordability career focused Community
hands-on experience and personalized
learning therefore only bootcamps offer
a convenient affordable and effective
way for individual to gain new skills
and Advance their careers
the importance of artificial
intelligence and machine learning in
2023 will continue to grow and expand
across various Industries and sectors Ai
and ml are closely connected and focus
on developing algorithms and systems
that can carry out activities that
commonly need human intelligence this
technologist will keep diving Innovation
productivity and growth across a range
of Industries they will play a crucial
role in helping companies and
organizations to maintain
competitiveness and relevance in a
rapidly changing environment as Ai and
ml continues to transform various
Industries this field has many exciting
job opportunities some popular job roles
in this field are machine learning
engineer data scientist AI research
scientist AI product manager Ian
software developer and many more you can
expect to earn a competitive salary as
an AI and ml engineer from glassdoors
salary estimated as of April 2023 the
average salary for an EI and ml engineer
in the United States is around 119 509
dollars per year in India it is 10 lakh
per annum you may develop your career as
an expert in artificial intelligence and
machine learning boot camp in
collaboration with Celtic the AI and ml
bootcamp offers master classes by Celtic
professors like classes thought by
industry experts interactive labs and
projects relevant to the industry this
bootcamp offers a chaotic academic
Excellence simply learned career
assistance campus emotions and hands-on
experience this EI enamel bootcamp will
help you get noticed by top hiring
companies and help you in the industry
relevant Capstone projects the AI and
machine learning bootcamp at Caltech is
the best option for anyone wishing to
get a Competitive Edge in the era of
cutting-edge Technologies this bootcamp
offers a complete understanding of AI
based Technologies like machine learning
natural language processing deep
learning speech recognization
reinforcement learning and other topics
this course covers tools and techniques
like python tensorflow Keras matplotlib
and many more along with industry
projects like social media e-commerce
manufacturing ethic Healthcare and many
other amazing projects choosing this
boot camp can get you hired by the
Renault companies like Microsoft Google
IBM Amazon Samsung and Adobe this
bootcamp has benefited many aspiring Ai
and ml engineers and professionals some
of them have shared their testimonials
you can look at their feedbacks on the
course page the link to which is in the
description box below the next cohort
starts on the 26th April 2023 to know
more about this intensive training
program which imparts job ready skills
and prepare you for the career as an AI
engineer check out the link below in the
description box below over the years the
need for coders has been raising
significantly and this trend is expected
to continue the demand for skill coders
to create and maintain software
application websites and other digital
products will only increase as more
firms turns to digitalization and
automation therefore as technology
advances the demand for coding
professionals is only expected to remain
high for the fusible future making it a
lucrative and in demand career path
there is a wide range of job
opportunities available in the field of
coding depending on your interest and
skill set here a few roles as software
developers front-end developers back-end
developers full stack developers mobile
developers cyber security Specialists
devops engineer and many more the
average salary for software developers
in the United States is around 120 000
annually in India it is 7 lakh per annum
according bootcamp is often a brief
intensive training course created to
assist students in becoming qualified
for a position as a software developer
it focuses on the Essential Elements of
coding and enabling students to use
those aspects right away to address
problems in the real world without
cutting edge caltex coding bootcamp you
can learn to code and become a full
stack developer in just six months
immerse yourself in our isolated coding
bootcamp to develop into a valuable
software engineer equipped to handle any
challenges at work this boot camp offers
a caltex academic Excellence Caltech
Campus Connect comprehensive career
service and hands-on experience
beginning with the fundamentals and
working your way up to more complex
aspects of full stack web development
this Caltech coding bootcamp will assist
you in mastering both front and back-end
Java Technologies in this online coding
bootcamp you will learn angular
springboard web service jsbase and
mongodb to help you start your career as
a full stack developer so let's get into
more details about this coding bootcamp
with the help of this Cutting Edge
coding bootcamp you can learn how to use
angular to create a robust online
application for your company the
fundamentals of various Frameworks are
covered including springboard web
service servlets and jail space MVC
JavaScript Bongo DB and many others this
course covers tools and techniques like
angular Docker HTML Marvin Java MySQL
AWS and many more along with industry
project like for delivery industry
entertainment industry healthcare
industry and many more Amazing projects
choosing this bootcamp can get you hired
by Renault companies like Microsoft
Google Oracle Netflix LinkedIn IBM and
Adobe this Caltech coding bootcamp has
benefited many aspiring software
developers and professionals some of
them have shared their testimonials you
can look at their feedbacks on this
course page the link to which is in the
description box below the next cohort
starts on 19th April 2023 to know more
about this intensive training program
which imparts job ready skills and
prepare you for a career as a software
developer check out the link below in
the description box data science has
become essential in various Industries
and Fields enabling us to make
data-driven decisions and gain valuable
insights from complex data sets it
involves using statistical and
computational methods to extract insight
and knowledge from data the importance
of data science can be seen in various
aspects of Our Lives including business
Healthcare education social science and
government data science is a rapidly
growing field and many job opportunities
are available depending on your skills
and interest job roles commonly
associated with data science May better
fit for you that includes data analytics
data scientists data engineer Big Data
engineer and many more the average
salary for data scientists in the United
States is around 126 000 annually in
India it is 12 lakford annum with the
help of this data science bootcamp's
live interactive sessions you can learn
to make decision based on data The
Bootcamp aimed at working professionals
including lectures from Top Caltech
professors interactive Capstone projects
and office hours this bootcamp offers
caltex academic Excellence Caltech
Campus Connect comprehensive career
service and hands-on experience the
Celtic data science bootcamp uses an
Interactive Learning format under the
direction of Industry professionals to
cover important data science topics like
Python Programming machine learning data
analysis and visualizations and more
additionally it has integrated Labs
where you can work on Capstone projects
and real world assignments and attend
faculty master classes from caltex ctme
this bootcamp covers data science
fundamentals including statistics Python
Programming data analysis machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing and data visualization tools
this course covers tools and techniques
like python numpy matplotlib tensorflow
pandas tab blue and many more along with
industry projects like sales analysis
for an apparel company employee
performance analysis classification of
songs for an audio streaming platform
and many more Amazing projects choosing
this bootcamp can get you hired in A
Renault companies like Microsoft Google
IBM Amazon Samsung and many more this
data science bootcamp has benefited many
aspiring data scientists some of them
have shared their testimonials you can
look at their feedbacks on this course
page the link to which is in the
description box below the next cohort
starts on 26th April 2023. to know more
about this intensive training program
that teaches you geography skills and
get you ready for a career as a data
scientist data analytics involves
collecting processing and analyzing
large data sets to extract valuable
insights and information in general data
analytics businesses to stay competitive
and make informed decision in today's
data driven world as business is
increasingly rely on a data-driven
decision making data analytics offers a
wide range of job opportunities across
numerous Industries some job
opportunities available in data
analytics include data analytics
business analytics data scientists data
visualization specialist and many more
as the demand for data analytics
continues to grow new job titles and
roles are likely to emerge the average
salary for a data analyst in the United
States is around 72 267 annually in
India it is 6 lakhs per annum the Celtic
data analytics bootcamp offered in
collaboration with Caltech will help you
stay in the front of the data Revolution
the data analytics bootcamp intended for
working professionals uses an applied
learning approach and includes
integrated labs and real-world projects
geared towards the business world this
course offers bootcamp academic
Excellence caltic Campus Connect highly
Interactive Learning and hands-on
experience working people of all
backgrounds will benefit significantly
from the Celtic data analytics bootcamp
learn fundamental skills like Excel how
to make data driven presentation how to
manipulate data with SQL how to analyze
data with python and how to visualize
data using Tableau learn data analysis
with AWS and other tools this
comprehensive caltic data analytics
bootcamp curriculum covers the ideas of
analytics using Excel data analytics
using python dealing with databases
using SQL data visualization with w and
data analytics on AWS this course covers
two and techniques like Excel SQL python
W and AWS choosing this bootcamp can get
you hired in the Renault companies like
Microsoft Google Amazon IBM apple and
many more many aspiring data analysts
have gained benefits from this data
science bootcamp and some of them have
shared their feedback you can find their
testimonials by following the link to
the course page in the description box
below if you are interested in becoming
a data analyst and accuring job ready
skills you should check out the
Intensive training program starting on
April 26 2023 which is the next cohort
find out more about this program the
link to which is in the description box
below cyber security is critical in
today's digital age because it including
personal information financial data and
intellectual property from theft damage
and unauthorized access therefore cyber
security is of utmost importance in
today's digital age and its significance
will only increase as more aspects of
Our Lives become connected to the
internet
the demand for cyber Security
Professionals is expected to grow in the
coming years making this an excellent
career choice for those interested in
technology and security the field of
cyber security is rapidly expanding and
many opportunities are available some
job roles in cyber security are cyber
security consultant penetration tester
cyber security engineer cryptographer
security operations center analyst and
many more the average salary for a cyber
security specialist in the United States
is around 91 000 annually and in India
it is 12 lakh per annum with the help of
our Celtic cyber security boot camp you
can Kickstart your career as a cyber
security specialist and gain the
experience and skills organization
required to protect sensitive data and
critical system from cyber attacks in
just 26 weeks this bootcamp offers a
cyber security bootcamp certificate
Celtic Campus Connect integrated labs
and hands-on experience the caltex cyber
security bootcamp will assist you in
gaining skills in a variety of areas
including infrastructure design digital
forensics penetration testing and
defensive and offensive cyber security
our course curriculum labs and assists
practices expose you to several
in-demand cyber security tools in 2020
the cyber security industry was
estimated to be worth USD
156.24 billion from 2021 to 2026 it is
expected to go up to at a cagr of 14.5
percent choosing this bootcamp can get
you hired by the Renault companies like
Netflix Oracle Amazon LinkedIn Google
and many more so if you're looking to
pursue a career as a cyber security
expert and acute skills that will
prepare you for your job consider
enrolling in this upcoming intensive
training program that starts on April 26
2023 which is the next cohort you can
learn more about this program by
clicking the link in the description box
below so with this we have come to the
end of this top 5 online bootcamp I hope
the bootcamp was informative and
interesting if you have any queries
regarding any of the courses covered in
this boot camp or need any help or for
any of this boot camps then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will be happy to Resort all your queries
at the earliest until next time thank
you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here